yt is better than coffee tea is filled
with health benefits including the
ability to possibly help prevent cancer
what do you got coffee you punk-ass
[ __ ] did you know that tea originated
3,000 years before coffee you need to
respect your elders son drinking tea can
help calm you down while drinking coffee
turns you into a caffeinated lunatic
hell-bent on eating babies people on
coffee crash hard but teen drinkers are
just like all right I'll guess I'll just
have some more tea
suck it coffee is a broad spectrum of
tea from white to black to frigging
flowers look at that I just made tea
[ __ ] out of flowers what does coffee
have oh it's just brown bean water
coffee yellows your teeth whereas most
teas actually contain fluoride to help
fight plaque dam making loose leaf tea
is a big deal in East Asian countries
which is why they have tea ceremonies
they Rock that Schmidt and it is
beautiful as hell look at that tea
unfurl hmm I feel myself reconnecting
with nature with every sip coffee grinds
just look like poop poopy poopy caca
look tea is not just about old ladies
and tea parties an old lady tea parties
[ __ ] in conclusion tea is the nectar of
the Gods and will keep you alive and
happy forever and coffee well
[Music]
Coffee can go [ __ ] itself